gaming keyboards are everywhere and you
might find it hard to pick one out for
yourself but I have the apex M 750 from
SteelSeries and I'm gonna tell you why
it's one of the standouts with game tech
we break down the tech that drives a
game to your love so do yourself a favor
and subscribe to GameSpot for more of
our content now into the keyboard first
things first the M 750 is 140 dollars
now that's actually a little bit cheaper
than most full-size mechanical keyboards
with full RGB lighting but the most
important part of a mechanical keyboard
is the mechanical switches now the M 750
uses SteelSeries is own oh snap damn
yeah the qx2 is steel series's own
mechanical switch which is a linear
switch similar to Cherry MX Reds there
won't be any tactile feedback and it's a
nice buttery smooth keystroke look at
that and they even color-coded these red
so there ain't no confusion the cubix do
has similar specs as the Cherry MX Reds
2 millimeter actuation point 4
millimetre travel distance and 45 gram
actuation force as someone who's partial
to linear switches the QX 2 is actually
one of my favorites because it's buttery
smooth but there is one thing you need
to take note here with the M 750 is that
the keys are loud loud it's a flaw
actually they're not that loud but they
are allowed now these aren't gonna be as
loud as Cherry MX blues where you can
hear every single click but these are
louder than most linear switches and
other keyboards that I've used but as
you can see look at that pretty
backlighting you'll notice that the M
750 has exposed key caps so you'll see
the RGB lighting kind of flowing out
through the chassis see how do you get
these pretty colors in these nice
effects will you use SteelSeries engine
software that lets you program how these
keys act and react it's some of the best
software I've used especially with all
the RGB options you get now I won't go
through all of them but I love using the
color shifting wave effect and the
ripple reactive effect on top of
the software lets you turn the
backlighting into an audio visualizer
and program of gifts color palette to
play out on the keyboard itself now
these are just novelties but other
lighting features can be useful for
example you can program a backlit
reaction to certain things that happen
in discord like a certain person
disconnecting or hopping in a channel
the gamesense feature lets you program
in game events to a back lighting scheme
now as a big Counter Strike global
Offensive Player I mess with having my
ammo health and armor count indicated
through a colored gradient of course
this info is on the screen in the game
but it was neat to have those colors
visible in my peripheral vision to
remind me of the in-game situations if
you're someone who uses other
SteelSeries devices you can program all
their lighting effects to work in unison
in terms of design the M 750 is built
with an aluminum alloy chassis which
does two things for it it's light weight
lighter than most mechanical keyboards
and it's very durable but I can't really
test that out because I don't want to
break the keyboard do I want to break
the key one
I'm sure it's durable I don't want to
find out how durable it is because I
like this keyboard we don't break things
here at GameSpot we should though
[Music]
now wait might not matter much for
something you don't pick up to use but
it does let me show you the nice grooves
and curves and the sleek design of the
keyboard looks pretty sweet huh you'll
notice this keyboard has a basic feature
set you won't have any macro keys you
can program yourself and you won't get
dedicated media keys which is something
I like a lot though if you press down
the function button it'll highlight each
key you can use for media which makes
finding the proper key a little easier
overall I like what the apex M 750 has
to offer but as a reminder it is gonna
cost you $140 and it only comes with
linear switches so if you're like me
who's really into linear switches and
likes the feel of it you'll feel right
at home with this keyboard if you're
scoping out other mechanical keyboards
be sure to check out our video reviews
of the Logitech G for 13 and the Corsair
k68 and if you're not subscribed to our
channel here at GameSpot please do
yourself a favor and subscribe thanks
for watching I'll see you next time